i went hunting i went hunting for
something
um and outdoors hunting
you know not just looking for something
like a remote control i'm talking i did
it i went out there
and i'll tell you about it so i uh
a friend of mine out here an adult he
knows a man
who does falconry you know deviant birds
and i'm not going to say that these
birds are caught up with the dark arts
but us
i mean they are each one of them had
probably half a can of voldemort in them
and that's really the truth and um
so the man does falconry
and um you know bobby kennedy jr had
talked about it when he was a guest on
here about
being around falcons and and you know
kind of
doing homing pigeons that sort of thing
when he was growing up
but basically what happened was we went
and met up with this man behind a church
or in front of a church actually first
first we met in front of a church
we pulled up he had a maroon van with
two decent uh
birds in it big you know big i'm talking
about these things where
these things were from the dam they were
from the middle of the bible these
things they was really
i mean these were you know some of the
get those game of thrones these these
birds
bro if these birds [ __ ] they would drown
a baby you know what i'm saying it was
all
they had these birds were they were real
birds
you know like you won't see if you see
one of these birds with a canary
it's only because they trying to [ __ ]
you know what i'm saying like these
birds was more about
they were more prehistoric prehistorical
you know like if you went back in time
and and you saw a bird it might be one
of these that's what i'm telling you
so we get out there and the man has two
falcons in the back of a red van
and i didn't believe him you know
because i grew up in kind of a you know
kind of a troubled area and a lot of
times a guy says hey i got two falcons
in the back of a van
somebody's breaking their dick out to be
honest
and uh but this guy you know he it was
they were real honest
and um and they had them you know and
everybody was clothed and they had the
birds
and so we go back behind the church and
he has a friend there another man
and now we're with two men adult men
and they both had on um
what is it called when you're hopeful
the
it's like a basketball rim but it's for
your hand it's like a
um jesus not a championship
uh they both had on wedding rings
and so next thing you know we get in the
woods they have the birds they have a
little dog too
and the dog and they're called uh
tumble creek falconry
i want to get the name right hold on i
think that was it
tumble creek falconry
and they do falconing and uh
and so anyway we get out there so they
give us a big stick
because they want you to have a big
stick if you're out there
this thing called what is it called here
uh
turnbull creek falconry and they're
legitimate
and so you get out there and they give
you a big stick like a big like a bottom
of an
axe like an axe like if you're
like if you're an axe person but you
quit axing
you know but you still want to have the
stick but you don't want to have the
blade
and they it's about four feet long and
you go you go along you beat the trees
right you beat the trees
and um and the birds first of all here
let me let me backpedal hold on
the birds um
the birds uh the birds they get them out
the cage they got helmets on they got
little
like uh hide and go seek little outfits
you know almost like if your grandmother
wanted if your grandmother
wanted to make you a hide and go seek
outfit for when you counted that it's
like a little
um it covers your eyes you know what
horses wear
if you ever been to a fancy city and
they got a couple horses down there
and they usually have an alcoholic
that's running them and they'll you know
for a few dollars they'll pull you and
your lady through the city
and you can ask her if she wants to
marry you or not or whatever you don't
have to ask her
a lot of times by the end of the horse
ride you're like damn i don't even want
to marry this woman
and so you just keep the ring in your
pocket and you go home
but um but anyway it's like the blinders
like the blinders so they have that on
the birds tudor birds they come out they
both got
uh little blinders on full blinders they
can't see anything
like if you asked them how many fingers
you were holding up they wouldn't squawk
so they got the two birds and um
and dude it feels like old school
it feels like you would be the it feels
like if you showed up with these things
you would get the most
[ __ ] at a renaissance fair and i'm
sorry for saying [ __ ] as well
so i want to say that also but um you
would be
oh you would have all the big titty
at a wren fair if you showed up with
these straight up just
falcons baby these heat seekers i'm
talking about the lord's freaking
southwest
airlines baby big birds
so anyway they come out with the little
head caps on and they're moving but it
looks like they're sleeping but
basically
um so then you start walking in the
woods you take off their head caps and
uh and they fly up into the trees
so now you have two birds up in the air
in the trees and sometimes they'll swoop
off and do us just a loopty loop and
come back to a branch
and so the rest of us men grown men
we wander and you get in different lines
and you wander through the woods
and everybody has like a piece of an axe
a stick an axe bottom an axe leg
i don't know what it's called axe leg
and you hit the trees
with it and you hit the underbrush
and you hit the tree
and you're hoping you round up a
squirrel
or rounds up a little rabbit you know
one of mr mcgregor's little buddies
little cotton tail
and you keep going and the birds they'll
as you walk the birds
they will kind of jump from they'll hop
their or kind of coast from one tree to
the next
so you guys are moving in like this like
this unique pack where they're upstairs
and you're downstairs but everybody's in
the same kind of move moving
hunt house it's like this you're just
it's not a real house but you're just
you know you're kind of in a pack
and then suddenly something will happen
like you'll hit a tree and it'll make a
and a little squirrel will have been
being real secretive
and he'll move his neck
and that that's all it takes for these
uh big birds is one just
just one jostle of a neck muscle and
they
and next thing you know they're on the
tree and they start to
they start to like uh corner the
squirrel
so we get the squirrel he move and they
corner the squirrel so one of the birds
gets ahead of it one of them blows it
and then they jump from branch to branch
and then next thing you know one of them
goes in for the attack
and uh and that was it man we you know
we did they did us
and that's nature you know people want
to say this and that that's nature baby
okay and it's all you know god laid out
those mar
those marbles you know he laid that's it
we're not you can say this and that but
that's
that's somebody else's plan don't talk
to me about it go pray about it if you
have an issue with it
because that's just that's what those
birds do
so anyway the birds were you know they
get a squirrel and then
oh and the birds will hold the squirrel
down it was wild so they
they caught one squirrel and then they
caught a
there's a little dog as well a little
white and black dog
maybe mexican i don't know i didn't get
a good look in his eyes but he was mixed
he was real real mixed man he uh
he had that jack russell in him baby
that eddie bravo you know what i'm
saying
and he was real pertinent he was real
particular he would go over he was only
hunting
and if you try to pet him or scratch his
belly he'd [ __ ] kick you bro this dog
it wasn't this wasn't no you know he was
on the job that's like a fedex man you
try to run up and tickle him or
something or
you know or hide one of his boxes he
might [ __ ] you up
and that's like this guy this this dog
was
so we went through
and what else did they catch they caught
a rabbit and a possum
and it was just magical man at the
beginning of the day i'm like scared of
the birds and by the end of the day
i'm like i'm just i'm like
i feel like the birds are like working
for me and i'm in
i mean i feel like i'm on the damn fifth
page of the bible baby i'm keyed up you
know what i'm saying we're hunting and
they're
picking up stuff i'm sending one of the
birds to go get me some uh
twizzlers and mike and ikes like these
br it's just really
you start to become like uh conan the
barbarian
and i thought about trying to do
something where i learn new stuff like
just how to do new things or have new
experiences
um because i've been looking for things
in the woods when i was young
but i'd never been actually really
hunting
you know accept a hunt oh actually
that's not true i've been i've been out
to hunt
pigs and i've been out to hunt uh boar
like boars but i've been out
been out to hunt um
ducks one time but you know i like that
hand-to-hand combat and it feels more
like that with the uh
with the with the birds with the hawks
there might have been hulks i think they
were
they might have been hawks but um not
atlanta i think they were from
well they must have been from here so
yeah local hawks but
uh whatever they were man it was
fascinating
it was fascinating and and yeah we got a
real experience and
it was like about a three four hour high
uh hunt
and it just i don't know it just made me
feel
so involved with nature you know it made
me feel right there i just felt
i just felt like a root
that's what i felt like and i'm used to
feeling like a branch
and it was pretty powerful hope you
enjoyed that video
and you can watch another and you can
watch this one you can watch this one
different options different choices some
guy just brings you one
option not this guy two options
watch one this one or this one
you